Donkey Kong Classics!
What's more fun than a barrel of monkeys?
A Donkey Kong Double Feature!
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. And I'm Joe.
And guys, today we are talking about DKC, not Donkey Kong Country, Donkey Kong Classics.
For the first time ever, Donkey Kong and DK Jr.
together. Except for they were together in Donkey Kong Jr.,
but one of them was in jail because of Mario or Jumpman, or actually his name was Mario in that one, not Jumpman like it was in Donkey Kong.
And Jumpman and Mario were in both of them, and now it's just the same games put on Donkey Kong Classics.
You guys get the idea, right?
Yeah, it's easy to follow.
So what you're saying is that there are two games on this cartridge.
Two games in one, Sean.
That's insane.
For the same value.
Yeah. So, you know, I don't know about you guys, but, you know, I remember Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr.
both pretty well,
and when I started up this game, I was kind of surprised to see that the menu had changed.
Yeah, the menu is very different now.
And maybe we could just, like, talk about that.
Well, it's got one of the, like, the classic color gamuts here.
Like, you've got sort of like a dark blue, or like a deep blue, and a sort of pinkish red for the title itself.
And you've got black and white outline, and then white text, and like a lighter blue for some less important text.
So I think it's a really good...
It's a really good palette to work with.
Now, do you think that that light blue with the dark blue is a solid blue dark background,
and then the light blue has, like, the copyright information for Nintendo, and the game that's not currently selected?
Do you think that that's just a little too close in color for each other?
I think that the color is fine.
I think what it says politically, though, is wrong.
I think that it's actually...
I feel like it's deliberately close in color, because it's like the game that you don't have selected.
So it's supposed to sort of, like, blend into the background a little more.
You don't know... It's not supposed to be as prominent as the one that you do have selected.
Right. And, you know, this kind of...
This is going to get me into a big rant, but I feel like we need to talk about this.
Is that in the original black box NES games, first off, there were never solid blue backgrounds.
I don't know why Nintendo all of a sudden got crazy here and made a colored background.
They were always solid black.
That's why we call them the black box games, right?
Indeed. Yeah.
We actually call them the black box games because the boxes are black, Sean.
That was a test. But, on top of that, you would hit the select button to change modes in those.
Because they always had, like, one player game A, one player game B, two player game A, etc.
You know? So you would hit the select button to change between those modes.
However, in this menu, you just hit the up and down arrows to select your mode.
And you hit the select button to change which game you want to be playing.
Now, what really makes that troublesome for someone like me is that I never understood the function of the select button anyway.
You weren't selecting your choice.
That's what the start button is for.
You see, the select button is more like an options button to shuffle through the options that are available to you.
So when you go from game A to game B, when you hit select, you're really not saying, I want to play game A.
You're saying, I would like to select the next option.
So why do you think the NES controller has a select button?
Well, I think it's weird just that they're using it in...
I know it's weird that they've used it at all.
But it's weird that they're using it in this.
If they're using up and down to go up and down, why aren't they using left and right to go left and right?
Joe, that's blowing my mind.
And I feel like that's why, you know, maybe a lot of people didn't buy this game because there's too much of a barrier to entry.
Like, you have to be a computer whiz to figure out how to operate it.
Well, to be fair, they put that in the manual, you know, like they do explain how to choose all this stuff there.
So thankfully, as long as you can read...
Nobody wants to read that thing.
Joe, I just tested the game.
And if you press left or right on the main menu, it does go between Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr.
Oh, it does. So the select button...
It does do left and right.
Does the select button also do that?
It very well may.
I did not test that.
I just wanted to make sure I could tell if you were wrong.
Great. Well, I appreciate that.
I appreciate that. Well, I was only going off of what Mike had just said, that select switches between Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr.
And then up and down switches between game A and game B.
And you know what?
I also just checked and the select button does do that as well.
But I wanted to make sure that we were 100% correct.
But if you ask me, like, why this system has a select button, I don't know.
Because I usually see the position that that button is placed.
That button is only for sharing gameplay footage.
And I guess, like, they just decided that they didn't want to do that with the NES and maybe this game specifically.
But every other game that I've played, that button is just for taking screenshots and streaming on Twitch.
That's true.
And, you know, another thing that I'm noticing now that I look at this menu screen a little more is that Donkey Kong, the O's in Donkey Kong have the stars from the arcade cabinet logo for Donkey Kong.
And that's pretty nice.
I always thought that was a little presumptuous.
Like, you know, I didn't play this on the arcade cabinet.
So why is it trying to force that aesthetic choice on me?
Well, here's my theory on that.
If you go back to the original Donkey Kong for the NES menu screen, there's no star in the actual title.
But the cursor that indicates which game mode you've selected is an asterisk.
Okay, so I think when Donkey Kong Jr.
came out, they brought in a new asterisk, a yellow one instead of a blue one.
So they retired the original asterisk and put a star in the junior to represent that original asterisk.
And now I think in this one, there are two stars, one representing the original Donkey Kong, one representing Donkey Kong Jr., and then a new asterisk representing this union.
Yeah, that's actually a very insightful look at that.
But to me, like, whatever symbolism and allegory it has in its typography, all I can see is the O's look too much like A's and it looks like it says Donkey Kong classics.
I would agree with that if there were any other O's on this screen that didn't have the star.
I would agree that that would be a little confusing.
Thankfully, the only O's on the screen also have the stars.
And there's an A in classics that shows us the difference between, like, what an A in this typeface looks like versus an O.
Right, I agree if you're thinking about it that much.
But to Sean's point, it could also be another, like, barrier to entry.
People don't know what game they're playing because they don't even get to the word classics.
By the time they read Donkey Kong, they're not sure what those letters are and they turn it off.
I'm already out.
Like, they've lost me once I've read those first two words.
Really, anyone who doesn't have a law degree can't play this game because there's so many trademarks and reserves and copyrights.
It's true. It's intimidating.
I think this is also the end user license agreement, like, for the game.
Well, because I also wonder, like, when I look at the screen, like, will I go to jail if I play this game?
Like, I don't, it's a registered trademark.
Can I play it? You can't actually display these things on your television without the express written consent of Nintendo.
Gotcha. They usually say stuff like that in the, on the manual anyway, at the end.
And there's, like, a whole thing, a final page of, like, don't put this on a chair.
Don't leave this on for more than 50 minutes.
There's a whole set of, like, rules that you legally agree to when you buy these games.
I forgot about not leaving it on chairs.
Well, because someone could sit on it.
It's true. Exactly.
Well, one nice thing about this menu, though, is that, so there is a box or a frame around Donkey Kong classics.
And it would have been really easy for them to just make a rectangular box.
Like, fine, easy.
No one probably would have complained.
But they really went.
They got those divots. Yeah, they went the extra mile.
And since Donkey Kong, those two words together, are longer than the word classics, they made a longer portion of the box to fit Donkey Kong than classics.
Which really just shows, like, how much care went into this game.
Because I know anyone who's used Microsoft Paint or Photoshop or anything knows that it's really easy to just grab that rectangle tool and make a perfect regular rectangle.
And if you didn't want to, like, put in the extra work, you just leave at that.
Sure, Joe. I mean, it's true.
This is better than just a rectangle.
But from my point of view, they shouldn't have been boxing this in any way.
You know what? Be a man and make a drop shadow.
You know? It doesn't have to have a box surrounding the letters.
Just let the letters stand with a drop shadow.
Yeah, it is hard to see the letters a little bit with that red against blue.
Yeah. I mean, again, it's one of the classic color palettes of our time.
But you're right, it does make it hard to see.
Do you guys think they're assuming too much here, though, by having Donkey Kong be selected first?
Like, automatically, if you don't know that you can select Donkey Kong Jr., you might think that you only bought Donkey Kong.
Right. And I have no idea how you select Donkey Kong Jr.
math. It's not even clear.
It's not in the manual. You know what?
That's something I wanted to get into.
When it's Donkey Kong classics, and there's no Donkey Kong 3, and there's no Donkey Kong Jr.
math, this is an incomplete collection.
No Donkey Kong country. Or they're saying those aren't the classics.
They very well may be saying that, but who gave them the right to say what is and is not a Donkey Kong classic?
The fans should have to say.
Should have their say.
You know, this is just a minor nitpick thing, but it's bothering me now.
Did you guys notice that one player, one player, two player, two player, the way it's structured on game A, game B, game A, game B, those are not, those are like one word.
Whereas game A and one player are all separately spaced with appropriate spacing, one player does not have a space between one and the P in player.
Yeah, that is interesting. I actually haven't noticed that, but I'll never unsee that now.
Yeah, I don't like that, but I think the biggest crime, and while it may be like this in other games, I still think it should be one player game A, and then two player game A, and then one player game B, and two player game B.
I think it should be separated by the game type, and not by how many players.
And why did they just stop at A and B?
They could have went all the way to Z.
Right, right.
And it's like they could have just done...
A, B, C, and D, and then you have to figure out for yourself, you know, make it a little more of a challenge for the player to figure out if it's going to be one player or two player and which game it's going to be.
Or there could be no menu at all and would just randomly drop you into any assortment of games.
Oh, I like that.
Kind of like a, like Togepi's metronome move.
From Pokemon, for those of you that don't know.
Everyone knows. You know, I don't want to harp on the menu for too much longer,
but just looking at the Donkey Kong Classics typeface again, since Sean really opened my eyes to this.
You know, does anyone else think that the L on Classics is just a little, little thin and longer than all of the other spacings on any of the other letters?
I didn't notice the thin, but I definitely think it's like taller.
No, no, no.
It's not taller, but it's, it's the, the bottom part of the L is actually longer than the rest of them.
It takes up too much space.
It's terrible kerning. Kerning.
That's the word I was looking for.
So honestly, this is, you know, this, this is the best of times, the worst of times on this menu right now.
Well, I think though.
Because I can't get over, the colors are just so great though.
But the one thing that we're all missing here is that if speaking of the colors, the background color, if you look at the negative space between the E and the Y, it's a backwards F.
So is that telling you that like this game is going to be like an F grade or is it going to be like fantastic?
Maybe it's saying that this game is fantastic.
And, and how Japanese of them to just in, you know, the way they're centering the font, the ass in classics is like front and center.
It's definitely, there's definitely some like hidden innuendos there.
Joe, you had mentioned, you know, at the closer to the top of this show about the, the blue star and the yellow star that, uh, or asterisks, whatever that select the game mode for you.
Mm-hmm. And, you know, do you ever think we'll see the yellow asterisk in like Super Smash Brothers as a character?
I think it's already an item.
Well, I, I think that the, the yellow asterisk has become, is actually the angry son in, in Super Mario Brothers 3.
I think that's where it ended up.
That makes sense.
That, I, that works out for me.
And I, I appreciate you adding that to the Super Mario lore.
Right. Yeah. I mean, I, I just assumed that everyone kind of like figured.
It's never been like explicitly stated, but it's like, look at it.
It's an asterisk. It's a yellow asterisk.
Now, do you think that there's any significance to how many points are on the asterisk?
Because there's eight. And usually when I see an asterisk, I see maybe six.
Is there, is there some numerology happening here?
Like, uh, is this, is this pointing to how many games Donkey Kong will eventually be in?
Uh, or how many they plan?
Well, you know, the NES is an eight bit system, so they could only, they could only hold up to eight directions on the asterisk.
You're right. I forgot.
Yeah. That makes sense.
Yeah. Instead of six, which they would have tried to do if they had enough.
Mm-hmm. Right.
If they were 16 bit.
Right. Then there's a six in the number.
So then they can do six.
Obviously. Yeah. But another thing about the asterisk I'm actually just noticing now is that it's really just sort of like, if you look at all the two vertical points and the two horizontal points, they're connected to the center.
But the diagonal points are just kind of tacked on, almost like they're behind it.
So is it even really an asterisk or is it like, yeah, is it like a star and then an X behind it?
I think it's saying that it's actually taking a religious stance.
Exactly. Well, you know that guy on YouTube?
That guy on YouTube who like boundary breaks the games?
Yeah. I think we need to do like a Donkey Kong Classic boundary break and see what's behind the asterisk.
How much depth there really is in there.
And I bet you, honestly, I bet you like if we start doing that, we'll notice that like the P in player is really small but close to the camera and the L is like gigantic but really far away from the camera.
You know, once you shift it, it's a whole different picture.
Well, now that I'm looking at it, and this is the last thing I'm going to say on the asterisk until we can actually get some research.
But if you look at it, if you squint just a little bit, it's actually a picture of a windmill.
Like the back side of a windmill.
Oh, yeah. Because, yeah, because you can see the center pole and that square shaped thing in the middle.
That's the building itself.
And then, you know, the diagonal lines, those are the blades of the windmill.
That would make a lot of sense because wasn't there, isn't there like some theory?
Isn't there something where the character of Donkey Kong is based on Don Quixote?
I believe so, yeah.
Okay, last thing on the asterisk, and then we're moving off of this.
But, you know, because it has eight points and everything, do you think that that could just be like the spider's legs?
And that's a spider?
And maybe that's the spider that like bit Peter Parker and turned him into Spider-Man?
Here's why I don't think that's the case, and that's because most spiders don't have legs that come out of their face.
And whatever, like, direction that this spider may be facing, one of its legs would have to be coming out of its face if that were a spider.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah, yeah, that's true, actually, because there's one that's facing directly forward.
But if it were true, it would be kind of interesting because, Sean, you keep talking about this unique color palette, red and blue.
That's Spider-Man's color.
That's his color. And those are the colors of Spider-Man, yeah.
So, I mean...
Now, I did not say red and blue.
I said, like, an off-red.
It's more of, like, a pinkish red, which is not Spider-Man.
It's more a color associated with Crazy Quilt.
So, I think it may be, like, a cross-promotion between DC and Marvel.
Well, that's fair, unless it's kind of more based on the first Sam Raimi film where he's wearing those, like, pajama Spider-Man.
I feel like it's closer to those colors than his actual Spider-Man suit.
It's very possible.
I just don't see it, like, in the canon.
Mm-hmm. That's fair.
Now, had the game not been called Donkey Kong Classics, what would you have called it that you think would maybe fit better within the realm and design constraints of this menu screen?
Spider-Man 4. Yeah, I see.
Like, you could say that.
I wouldn't say that.
I would...
But you could. You could say that.
You could put those syllables together and say those words.
Mm-hmm. But I wouldn't. Because here's what I would call it.
I would call it...
I would...
You know, because two games, Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr., I would make a portmanteau of those two games and call it Donkey Kong Jr.
Oh! Oh, I like that.
Yeah. For anybody keeping score at home, the red in Donkey Kong Classics is actually hashtag D33355.
And the blue is color hashtag 2300B7.
I don't know if I'm allowed to legally give out those hexadecimal values.
No, no, no. Yeah. We're going to have to cut that.
Yeah. But now you can picture it.
But I think to Joe's point, it would help you picture it better had you have known those hex values.
That's true. Yeah. It's...
I do have a...
Everybody can kind of translate hex value to color in their head.
Yeah. That's how seeing works.
Here we go.
We're finally here.
Performing for you.
If you know the words, you can join in two.
Put your hands together.
If you want to clap.
As we take you through this funky rap.
Hey, P.K.
Punky Kong.
He's the leader of the bunch.
You know him well.
He's finally back to kick saw's tail.
His coconut gun can fire in spurts.
If he shoots you, it's gonna hurt.
He's bigger, faster, and stronger too.
He's the first member of the D.K.
crew. Hey, P.K.
You know, Joe, that is a good point that that's what seeing is for.
And, you know, speaking of just seeing the menu, there's also, like, an entire game here.
Just beyond the menu.
There's two, actually.
You're right. Wait.
There's Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr.
Donkey Kong Jr.
Yes. Now, how do these games hold up for you, Sean?
Um, I mean, they, I remember when we, when we did our very intimate Donkey Kong sessions, just you and I.
I can't even remember what our verdict was on how they, on how they, they handle the day.
But they play exactly the same.
There's absolutely no difference.
Um, in fact, I remember when we were talking about the omission of one of the Donkey Kong levels, we thought it was just because, you know, there's not enough space on the, the ROM.
Um, but the fact that they could squeeze in Donkey Kong Jr.
on this thing makes me very much doubt that.
Yeah, I'm in 100% agreement with you there.
I'm kind of surprised that they would, uh, bring Donkey Kong exactly the same here, put Donkey Kong Jr.
on it, and still not give us the Pie Factory level.
Yeah. So, I mean, it actually makes me more angry at this game for not being complete.
It's funny, too, because I, I always thought that, too, that it's, like, just, it was just a space issue.
But then we just think about all of the other, like, hundreds of games we're playing.
They all fit more on it than, like, what seems to exist in these three levels of Donkey Kong.
So now that I think about it, why would I have ever thought that?
Like, why did I ever think that?
Well, you know why?
Because it, it, it would, you're putting good faith in Nintendo here.
But they don't care because they made this, they released this version of Donkey Kong back in 1983 as the very first game for the Famicom.
And Donkey Kong Jr.
was the other launch title for the Famicom.
So when you have two launch title Famicom games, you bring them over to North America and you change nothing about them.
And then you re-release them together and say, okay, but we're still going to leave them exactly the same.
The only person you're helping there is the person who got screwed over the first time when they bought Donkey Kong.
So they don't feel inclined to buy this classic version.
Yeah. The fact that there is nothing added makes me wonder, like, what the point was.
If it's just, if it's the equivalent of games going on sale and you get two for one because they're so old now, maybe.
But I guess I don't really know aside from maybe this being bundled.
Yeah. I think of bundling it as, like, kind of the best way that I can think of it.
I mean, if you think about it, I'm sure, like, everybody that you've ever met has once owned Super Mario Duck Hunt.
Like, right? Like, everybody had that somewhere.
Super Mario slash Duck Hunt.
And I just felt like that was just such a normal thing.
I was like, yeah, it made sense.
Even though I never really thought about it.
It made sense. Yeah. You just put two games together that are really popular.
So maybe it was just like they knew people would buy this bundled together, you know?
I think it's a smart move to bundle the games, especially something like Donkey Kong, which was huge in the arcades when it came out.
Another thing that we're not really considering, and I'm going to continue to seesaw my opinion on this as I go on.
But Donkey Kong is the big Nintendo name right now in terms of, like, mascot characters, right?
Super Mario Brothers took off in 1985 and everything.
But Donkey Kong is, like, what really started Nintendo on this hot track of video games.
And it's only once, like, Mario continues to have success with Super Mario Brothers and Super Mario Brothers 3 and Super Mario World.
Like, you know, he becomes the face.
But Donkey Kong is, like, the start of everything.
And Mario is just a character in that universe.
Now it's almost like this release of Donkey Kong Classics is supposed to usher in, like, the, oh, but don't forget about our mascot, Donkey Kong.
Like, we want everyone, you know, brand awareness and everything.
And that makes sense.
But then they go on to never release another Donkey Kong game until Donkey Kong 94.
Yeah, this seems to be the last gasp of Donkey Kong as the mascot.
But beyond that, they're not doing, they're not putting their all into saving him.
You know? You'd think that they would make a better game.
Yeah, it almost feels like, right, it feels like you would want this Donkey Kong Classics, you would want, like, Super Mario Classics,
in which we get, like, Super Mario Brothers and Super Mario Brothers 2, the Japan one, on the same cart.
And that's how you, like, alleviate the stress of buying, like, Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan.
You know, instead we get Super Mario Brothers 2 here later on this year and what would be referred to as Super Mario Brothers USA moving forward.
But I feel like that would have been an appropriate way to introduce the Japanese version of Super Mario Brothers 2 to this American audience is by bundling it with Super Mario Brothers 1.
It's this way it's like you get the game you love plus a brand new version of that same game.
Whereas Donkey Kong Classics isn't really offering any kind of, like, incentive.
Yeah, there's no additional value here.
Yeah. If you already own the games, there's no reason to buy this.
So, Joe, you weren't on the Donkey Kong episode, but how do you feel about, like, Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong Jr.'s video games?
I mean, on one level, as, like, you know, as playing it on an NES and it being very obvious that this is an older arcade game,
I think that shows to me a lot.
This doesn't feel like if I had no nostalgia for Donkey Kong in the arcade, I don't think I'd be that interested after playing it on the NES.
But then even, I think, as an arcade game, just my personal preference, I've always thought it was a little more popular than it is good, at least in my opinion.
I mean, it's fine. I know you guys really liked it a lot on the episode, if I remember correctly.
I think it's fine.
It's fun. It's a game.
It operates. Historically, it's very important.
But I just always think that, like, it doesn't stand out to me.
Got it. I think I'll say that Donkey Kong Jr.
is not getting better as I continue to play more video games.
But Donkey Kong has always had, like, a soft spot for me, and maybe it's just because I played it early on in my life that I still enjoy it.
However, I do have one very specific nitpick about Donkey Kong here.
And that is that they're in the NES version specifically, not the arcade, there just seems to be a, like, muscle memory error in me that causes me to miscount the number of climbs on a ladder.
And I always seem to, like, just be one too short before I, like, am able to move left or right before I'm actually able to.
Yeah, I did the exact same thing.
I was just stuck on that, just hovering above the ladder, acting like I was still on it, and a barrel was coming right from my face.
I'm glad I'm not the only one.
Just to give you a little development thing here, in an early issue of Nintendo Power, they referenced the return of Donkey Kong, which is the name of the video game.
And there's, like, a little teaser about it.
We'll link to it in the show notes.
This is not that return of Donkey Kong game.
Or is it?
See, I would argue that this is the return of Donkey Kong game, and that they were never working on, like, a Donkey Kong 4 or a new version of Donkey Kong.
And that the return of Donkey Kong was just teasing the Donkey Kong classics thing.
And maybe Nintendo of America, who works on Nintendo Power, just didn't get the memo that this is what it was going to become.
But I do think hyping up a return of Donkey Kong and not getting the Donkey Kong game I pitched back on the Donkey Kong 3 episode, which is finally being able to control Donkey Kong and fight Mario that way, which would have been an amazing game.
To never get that, and to have this instead be the return of Donkey Kong, it hurts.
No, I was just going to say, I think, like, for us looking at it now, or at least for me looking at it now, it seems so much less of a big deal because it's like, yeah, a bunch of these things exist from the past.
But, you know, if you do think about it in the lens of, like, you are a Donkey Kong fan in the 80s and you're waiting for this new game to come out and then the new game is just the old game.
I can see why that is, like, a much bigger deal than, like, now just being like, oh, why is this bundled?
Well, I mean, I also don't think that, as much as we've kind of messed around, I don't think that anyone was fooled by this.
I don't think that there was an announcement and lots of anticipation about these two games on the same cart.
Right. But it just seems odd that this would be the business decision.
Unless it was bundled with the console.
Yeah, feels like you would want to at least include Donkey Kong 3, but they were smart enough not to include that, thankfully, because I hate that game.
Yeah. Hey, yo!
Look out, down below
Here he comes, Banana Slammer
Come on, go, hero
Hey-oh
Donkey Kong, let's go, let's go
Here he comes, Banana Slammer
Anyway, you know, this was just making me think about something that's pretty
It's having a moment in the video game industry since at least the tail end of the
or maybe the, sorry, the beginning of the PS4, Xbox One generation of consoles
and that's that whole like remake, remaster, re-release trend of video games that we always see
Where do you guys like find yourself in the mix of all these things?
Are remakes okay?
Are remasters preferred?
Do you even pick up games that are just straight re-releases?
I'm thinking about like that Mafia trilogy that just got announced and was released like simultaneously
and that's like the weird mix of like one game is a straight up re-release
the other one's a remaster and the first one's a remake
like that is super strange, right?
We never really see something like that
Yeah, but I think it's super interesting
and I'm not for or against one over the other
I think that there are a lot of remakes that have done good by its source material
There are a lot that have completely just wasted it
Like I remember there was a game from the 90s, Syndicate
which was like a, not tactics, it was like a squad-based shooter
And then Syndicate comes out on like PS3, Xbox 360 generation
and it's just another FPS game
So that was a remake that nobody asked for and nobody liked
But you can also ruin remasters
Like when Silent Hill 2 and 3 were released together
that sounded like the perfect thing for me to buy on the newer systems
but they actually mess those games up
They are objectively worse than their original
So I think like it really depends on why the games are being remastered
Is it because the developers think that they deserve better fidelity
or is it because they're trying to make a quick buck?
So I kind of have a muddled opinion on them all
Yeah, got it
And Joe, I just would love to hear before you dive deeper
I'd love to hear your thoughts on just like
what counts as a re-release for you
what counts as a remaster and what counts as a remake
Well, so the way I always looked at it
was that a remaster is
is if something is taken
the original files, the original game is taken
and maybe up-resed and maybe a few little like
interface details are added
and it's made compatible with like the current generation
That could not be the actual definition
but that's what I always assumed
I would agree with that
Whereas a remake is like
either taking the original game
and using it as your roadmap
to make the game again
now with the current technology
like the Crash Bandicoot Insane Trilogy
which is literally just the original games
now with better graphics, a little better controls
and, you know, a few other little things added to it
but it's like clearly a game that was made from scratch
or something like the Ratchet & Clank
remaster of the original game
which, I'm sorry, remake of the original game
which is really
what I would, not to add too many re-words into it
but I would consider more of a re-imaginate
where it's
here's a new origin story
with some references to the original
but it's a completely new game
See, I would just call that a remake
But didn't we say that
Crash Bandicoot is also a remake
where it is the original game?
I thought that was your definition of a remaster
If I said that, that I
I meant
a remaster
being like if you were to take Crash Bandicoot on the PS1
take that exact game and up-res it
whereas remake being
you take that game and use it as your roadmap
to make the game again
with like all new assets
Yeah Or
a remake I think would also be
the like a remake is
I think like a re-imagining also
is like a subset of a remake
which is like just my own arbitrary definition
but No, I understand
Right, I see what you're saying, Joe
It's worth asking like
is
is Metal Gear Solid
The Twin Snakes
a remake of Metal Gear Solid 1
or is it its own game
because it differentiates itself enough
similar to like the new Final Fantasy 7 remake
you know I haven't played it
but if the source material
is different enough
is it a remake
or is it a re-imagining
like a new category
of things They're both remakes
and I think that
there are two different flavors
there's the remake
which is like well it may not be the same code
like a remaster
it
it hits the same
beats
it plays
in the same genre
with maybe
one system
fiddled with and then there's the more
there's the more
full makeover
sort of remake where it may even
change genres
like
as long as it
it has enough
borrowed from the original
it still qualifies
as a remake to me
So Sean
that checks out for me
and this is
this is just a
test of your opinions
and stuff so I just want to hear
your true input on this
but like
so for Final Fantasy 7
switching from
turn-based to ARPG
right like
say Fire Emblem
did that with like
an older entry
in their strategy RPG
but now they made it
more like
a action
adventure style game
where they still follow the same
the same
characters
and plot and those things
happened but now it happened
under a completely
different genre
of video games
would you still put that in the
remake territory I say I would
I'm just wondering where you would
think about that something like that
it's that's very interesting
because they are both
games that
much of their
identity comes from
the
the systems
the gameplay systems
maybe not not just the story
or not just the
setting but Final Fantasy
as a series
used to be
the typical
turn-based
each both of you
stand on different sides of the room
and tick turns hitting each other
sort of thing like that
was that was
just as descriptive
of Final Fantasy
as Cloud Strife
and Midgar were
but over time
the series
changed it
there were different battle
systems and now
like Final Fantasy
can be any
number of
different kinds of
games whereas
you would
think that's the same with Fire
Emblem but there's a
much more purest
element to I think
like people
who enjoy Fire
Emblem games that if
you changed just like
if it
wasn't the tactics
game I don't
think people would call it Fire
Emblem anymore so
I think
it it's
interesting question and I
don't think I can answer it
I would still
call them I would
still call it a remake
but it would
probably be
a
subpar remake
if they decided
it wasn't going to be tactics
anymore whereas I
don't feel the same
about Final Fantasy 7
since Final
Fantasy in general has
been moving towards that
ARPG
ever since
7 got it
and you know it's a
very long answer I think
it's good
when it comes down
to it you know
I think all three
of these things
even though there are
so many of them right now
I think it's
all good
by me and it
just comes down to a case
by case basis
you know like I enjoy
remakes in the sense
of seeing a game
that was you know
maybe at one time
highly praised
but has you know
as time goes on
has become kind of obtuse
like it's cool to
see those kind of games
get a remake
so this way you can play
them the way the games
are currently being played
you know and then
on the same thing remasters
I think
that's neat
but at
a certain point that kind
of only has a
certain amount of generational
leaps to it
like no one's
making Chrono Trigger
remastered
and just using
2D sprites
and just making
them better looking
that's just
not happening aren't they
haven't they done
that a few times not super
recently but in the last few
years but do you
guys consider those like
do you consider that like
a remaster
of Chrono Trigger or just like
a re-release
of Chrono Trigger like which one
does that fall under for you
I would consider
some of the stuff they've done
with Chrono Trigger remaster
like the I know it was
a while ago now but
the DS
release yeah
I consider that a remaster
they did add some new
content and they
but they also like adjusted
the interface to be a little
you know a little
less intrusive
I mean I guess
because they had two screens
they were able to do that but
but they
changed enough where I would
consider that to be a remaster
and I even had
to do PlayStation 1
cutscenes so
that's right even on
PlayStation 1 was that
I mean I guess that would be a remaster
technically I think
it would have to be right
it is a remaster
I think that once you get to
things like Skyrim
which gets released
on everything and it doesn't
matter which it doesn't matter
which generation it's on
I just keep calling
those re-releases
even though I guess
there was a remaster
at one point
but
yeah the lines blur
a little bit
but you just
kind of go with your gut
I would I would call
the various
Chrono Trigger
releases remasters
because they do
change art
which I wouldn't
do in a re-release
right as we've been
talking about this too I've been
kind of grappling
with what my opinion is on
what kind of
remake
I like better
or like I would
generally prefer for someone to do
because I do think
that this might
just be a coincidence
but but the
examples
I mean I can only
really think of one right now but I think
like anytime where
someone does a remake
where they're
they're really trying to just
retell the story
in a new way or like
use just like
use the the source as
inspiration but
change it a lot
I think like
I find that to be
the more ambitious
choice and
and maybe there's
more potential for
something better because you're
getting something new but like
I'm thinking of
Ratchet and Clank where they did that
and I think it just
failed because
they're taking I mean I know
it succeeded and
I know it was like a popular game
I personally
thought that they
were taking a game
that was a classic
because it was so good and they
tried to change so
many things and make it so
different that just like
the odds are
they've made a worse game
and I and I think
that that is like
the the risk
reward I feel like
it's I feel like
I'm more wary
wary of
a game doing
that because I'm more worried
that they're going to screw
it up hopeful that
they'll do better but then when
someone does like I'm just
going to remake this game
exactly the way it was with
all new assets like they did
with Crash Bandicoot
or like they did with Shadow of the
Colossus where they changed
very little things
kept it mostly intact
at least I know
I'm getting that game which I
know there's like a problem
it's like you're just getting the
same thing again but now I can
play it on current gen systems
and it can look
prettier there are definitely
more ways to fail
with a remake than there are
with a remake because I was
trying to come up like decide
like do I
prefer them
to just stick
to the to the way it originally
was and just up res it
and I think that's where my
brain goes because I've
had more good experiences with
that but then
if I think like more philosophically
like should you
just take like
not try and change anything
like if you can make a better
game of course try but I
just think that there's it's all
a big non sequitur but I just wanted
to talk about
that I think
there's more room
for failure like you said
all right I mean this has been a
great discussion and I'm not sure
how much of it
has to do with Donkey Kong
classics which I
think definitely falls under the
whole just like re-release category
and within the
same within the
same system that
it it debuted
on which is strange you know
like like usually
a re-release at
least happens like a system later
or something like
you would see it on the on the
super NES but
you know I think
we should wrap this up with our
essential games list
votes so you know
we can keep that as brief as we
want but let's
get into the
essential games
list okay Joe since
you were not on
the original episode I'd love for you
to vote first okay well spoiler
for my original the original episode
for either of
these I would say
that neither of these as stand
alones were essential games
so I don't think
putting them together makes
them makes them
essential to me sorry there's not
much much for me
to explain there so that's just
kind of my my
short and sweet
essential games
let's vote not essential all right
great and Sean
yeah regardless of
whether these
uh individually
were essential
or not uh it would
it this wouldn't
be essential to smashing them
together so uh
my perfunctory
no vote has been
cast you know
this was a this
was a chance to
redeem uh the
lackluster ports of
the very first
Famicom games you
know like I think people were a little
more forgiving because
it was the first thing like the
Famicom was built
to play Donkey Kong
and now in 1988
uh you know five
years later and
they've chose to do
nothing to change
these and I get
that like in terms
of console games at
this point playing
arcade games like this is a totally
fine way to play
Donkey Kong but it's
not even the complete version and that's
just so strange and
then to like to like
have the full version
of Donkey Kong Jr. but not the full
version of Donkey Kong
and put them on the same cart I don't
really know what's going on here it's
it's it's a little
bizarre so it does
it doesn't get on the essential games
list but I would like to say that
even if Donkey Kong
and Donkey Kong Jr. weren't on the
essential games list
there was a chance
for a game that
combines both of
them changes enough
and adds in like
some extra features
as well there's a
chance to like make
a game like that get on the essential
games list so they
did squander an
opportunity here so
it's not too late though it's not too
late Nintendo if they
want to re-release Donkey Kong Classics
2 for the NES
for the NES we're
buying all right
Donkey Kong all
stars for anybody
who made it all the
way through this episode congratulations
we talked about
we talked about so
much so thank you
so much for listening next week
we have Ghostbusters
so you know anyone
who lived through the 80s loves that movie
and everything that
came after it for the
Ghostbusters and
including every single
film they love every
single film version of
Ghostbusters I've never heard of
somebody that did it so with that in mind
we're going to look forward to playing the
NES Ghostbusters game
next week and you should play along too
and listen to the
episode if you can you can find us on
Twitter at Nostalgia
Cast I'm Michael
Esposito you can find
me at Esposito Film on
Twitter and I'll talk to
you soon you
I'm blue I'm blue
I'm blue I'm